all right john thank you a federal judge
meantime has dismissed the criminal case
against former trump administration
national security adviser michael flynn
but judge emmett sullivan pointedly
noted flynn's pardon from president
trump does not mean
that he is innocent the president
tweeted congratulations to flynn saying
he and his family had suffered
greatly let's get some additional
perspective on these legal fights
jonathan turley is a professor at george
washington university law school
and a fox news contributor jonathan good
evening let me start with the
pennsylvania
decision by justice alito he turns it
over to the full supreme court
no noted dissents and they do not move
forward there's no injunctive
relief there is that a big blow for the
president's chances
it is a big blow you know we've talked
in the past about how
the president was running out of runway
and at this point
to really make a difference he'd have to
land a jumbo jet on a postage stamp i
mean he does not have a lot of runway
left
this was considered his strongest case
for the supreme court
and the court system has proven that it
is independent
in reviewing these these claims many of
these are trump appointees
who are voting against the position of
the president not because they have
animus
but because they don't see the legal
case
particularly in terms of the relief of
blocking certification
there is this sticker shock that kicks
in for these
courts saying look there are problems
that you've identified
there have been illegal orders in other
cases there have been
votes that have been negated but they're
asking for
a really massive form of relief which is
blocking certification now at the same
time
it'd be nice if some democratic senators
um actually apologize to people like
barrett
and others you know during her hearing
they put out these conspiracy theories
that she was being put on the court
to kill the aca or steal the election
none of that seems to be true obviously
you say he's running out of runway and
just look at the electoral college
timeline here today was the deadline to
resolve disputes actually
december 14th the electors vote in the
states december 23rd the state's
certified deliver the votes
january 6 the house and senate joint
session count the votes declare
officially
the winner there is this other case that
john mentioned out of the texas
attorney general filing to the supreme
court directly
court watchers are looking at how this
particular pennsylvania case was dealt
with
40 minutes after the filings came in
does that suggest that they're just not
in the mood to take care of anything
else like this
i'm afraid that texas case falls in that
category of that dog won't hunt i mean i
don't see how that's going to be
successful
particularly after this loss and yes the
timing was notable this
the ink was hardly dry on the filing
when the court came back and basically
ended this issue
uh so i think that it does not look very
promising last few days we've also
noticed the trump campaign
and president trump himself are talking
more about going to the legislatures
you'll notice on his list
of people that could change this the
first justice was number three
he talked about a legislator or
legislatures
and that's a straight muscle play that's
an effort to try to get
legislatures to say we don't want the
certification of these votes to go for
biden
that is also not likely to succeed
but it does show a shift away from the
court
finally uh judge m matt sullivan
wrapping up this criminal case against
michael flynn
he was pardoned by president trump but
notable that judge sullivan
had this detail in this final filing
about how he's not he doesn't have to be
innocent
just talk for a minute about the how
he's handled the judge has handled this
entire thing
well you know i've practiced in front of
judge sullivan for years i've had great
respect for him
but i've been very critical of his
handling of the flynn case
you know he has been criticized for
years of using
general flynn as a vehicle for
criticizing the trump administration
refusing to dismiss the case the
prosecutors came in and said we
no longer want to charge michael flynn
we no longer believe
a charge is appropriate and the justice
department filed
for a dismissal judge sullivan refused
court of appellate court of appeals
judges in the first panel
criticized him and ordered him to
dismiss the case that was later reversed
because they wanted to give the judge a
chance to issue a final order
but even then he would not dismiss the
case and when the pardon came down he
still held on to the case
and now he has finally dismissed it but
in doing so i think that
it was really grossly inappropriate for
him to
essentially declare a verdict of a
person who wasn't even
sentenced that's what this was and you
know judges
usually don't even address the guilt of
a defendant until sentencing
they certainly avoid that when you're
having a dismissal of a case they don't
talk about guilt or innocence because
the defendant doesn't have a right to
appeal
those types of gratuitous comments and
that's what this was
it was gratuitous and it was wrong for
the court to do it
jonathan turley as always thank you